Salut tout le monde,
j'espère que vous allez bien.
Dans cette vidéo,
on va parler de la guerre en Ukraine.
Le 24 février 2022,
la Russie a décidé d'envahir le pays,
et avec Camille Courcy, on est partis sur place,
pour aller dans la capitale Kyiv.
À ce moment-là, on ne savait pas du tout
combien de temps l'armée ukrainienne
allait tenir face aux troupes
de Vladimir Poutine
et on entendait quasiment toutes les heures
les sirènes d'alerte dans la ville
qui annonçaient des potentielles attaques
de l'aviation russe.
Une guerre, c'est toujours
hyper compliqué à expliquer parce que
y a beaucoup de propagande,
mais dans cette vidéo, je vais quand même essayer
de vous raconter ce qu'on a pu voir sur place
et aussi vous expliquer
ce qu'on a vu passer sur les réseaux sociaux.
L'aviation russe a bombardé
lourdement Kyiv toute la nuit,
ça a même continué
jusqu'au petit matin.
Là, on vient d'arriver dans un quartier
où un immeuble a été touché
par un missile
à 8h.
Y a encore de la fumée
qui s'échappe du bâtiment.
Tout un pan de l'immeuble
s'est ensuite écrasé
sur le magasin juste en dessous,
donc il y a eu énormément
de dégâts matériels.
Je vais vous montrer la rue,
à quoi ça ressemble.
On peut voir que le souffle a été
extrêmement puissant,
parce que y a des débris
sur plus de,
je dirais, 200 à 300 mètres,
autour de l'immeuble.
À cause des bombardements
et des combats dans Kyiv les premiers jours,
des milliers d'Ukrainiens se réfugient
dans les sous-sol de la ville
et dans des bunkers.
On a pu filmer
dans l'un d'entre eux,
mais les soldats ukrainiens
nous ont demandé
de garder secret
la localisation du bâtiment
pour des questions de sécurité.
Ici, on est dans ce qu'on appelle
un "shelter".
C'est un abri anti-bombardements
très bien protégé,
qui est à plusieurs dizaines de mètres
de profondeur,
et tous les jours, il y a entre 150 et 200 personnes
qui viennent se réfugier ici.
Le 4e jour
de l'offensive russe,
la 2e ville du pays, Kharkiv,
est prise d'assaut,
mais résiste.
Là-bas, les combats sont
extrêmement violents.
Avec les images
de la guerre en Ukraine,
les sanctions internationales
se multiplient contre la Russie.
Face à ça, Vladimir Poutine
brandit la menace ultime :
il mobilise
ses forces de dissuasion nucléaire.
La plupart des images
qui arrivent des lignes de front
un peu partout dans le pays,
elles sont souvent filmées
par des civils ou des militaires ukrainiens,
et elles montrent bien
la violence des combats.
Avec les images
des réseaux sociaux,
on voit bien que les Ukrainiens
se mobilisent dans tout le pays.
Et dans certaines villes
prises par les Russes,
on voit même des images
de civils désarmés
qui tentent de freiner
l'avancée des chars.
À ce moment-là,
des centaines de milliers d'Ukrainiens
ont déjà fui le pays.
Mais les hommes
entre 18 et 60 ans
ont l'obligation de rester
pour participer à l'effort de guerre.
Tout le monde est appelé
à prendre les armes.
Les autorités ukrainiennes distribuent
des fusils d'assaut
et tentent de former les civils,
en seulement quelques jours,
pour grossir les rangs de l'armée.
Là, on est à un endroit
où les civils sont entraînés
par des militaires confirmés
à utiliser des fusils d'assaut.
Il y en a beaucoup
qui ont déjà eu
une forme d'entraînement
parce que la guerre
a commencé en 2014.
Mais sinon, la majorité
d'entre eux
n'ont jamais tenu
une arme de leur vie.
Dans ce centre d'entraînement,
il y avait, évidemment,
des profils très différents
parmi les civils.
On a rencontré Julia,
une professeure de littérature.
Des civils, comme Julia,
qui ont voulu rester pour se battre,
on en a croisé des dizaines
pendant notre tournage,
notamment dans les quelques magasins
d'équipement encore ouverts dans Kyiv.
Tous les Ukrainiens qui ont
choisi de rester pour se battre
n'ont pas pris forcément
les armes dès le début.
Certains participent
à l'effort de guerre autrement.
Là, je suis dans une cuisine
d'un restaurant de la capitale Kyiv
où des citoyens sont mobilisés
pour préparer à manger
pour les civils qui ont pris les armes
et pour l'armée ukrainienne.
Ils préparent tout,
toute cette nourriture
qui part ensuite sur le front.
Partout où on va,
ce qui est hyper impressionnant,
c'est la participation de toute
la population à l'effort de guerre.
Il y a vraiment un vrai
sentiment national
de "il faut qu'on défende notre pays"
et tout le monde participe.
- Pourquoi c'est important, pour toi,
ce que tu es en train de faire là ?
- Parce que je suis fière
de ce que nous faisons.
J'adore vivre en Ukraine.
C'est mon choix.
Moi, je crois beaucoup à l'Ukraine
et au futur de l'Ukraine, à l'avenir.
- Toi, t'as pas eu envie,
par exemple, de prendre les armes ?
- Je voulais beaucoup, mais le truc,
c'est qu'il n'y a plus de place, en fait.
Tout le monde est engagé
et très motivé.
Là, ils ont des matelas,
des coussins,
des couettes.
En fait, s'ils veulent, ils peuvent
rester ici dormir sur place
et vu que c'est un sous-sol, ils sont
aussi protégés un peu des bombardements.
Ils se disent qu'en restant ici,
ils peuvent continuer
à travailler en permanence
et continuer à amener
de la nourriture sur le front.
Les civils qui ont pris les armes
sont postés un peu partout dans Kyiv
à des checkpoints.
Ils contrôlent tout le monde,
parce que
l'armée ukrainienne soupçonne
la présence d'infiltrés russes dans la capitale.
Le 1er mars,
on est toujours dans Kyiv avec Camille
et on apprend,
avec cette photo satellitaire,
qu'un immense convoi
de chars russes,
de plusieurs dizaines de kilomètres,
se dirige vers la capitale.
L'armée russe avance, en fait,
dans plusieurs directions
et les fronts se multiplient
dans tout le pays,
notamment au sud,
particulièrement dans les villes de
Kherson et Marioupol.
Nous, à Kyiv, on entend des bombardements
pas loin du centre-ville
et on apprend,
quelques heures plus tard,
que c'est la tour de diffusion
de la télévision ukrainienne
qui a été touchée.
Une partie de la structure a été
complétement calcinée à cause de l'explosion.
Toutes les vitres ont été
blastées par le souffle
et c'est pareil dans tous
les immeubles aux alentours.
Et il y a un bilan humain
derrière ce bombardement.
Il y a cinq personnes
qui sont décédées
et cinq personnes qui ont été blessées.
On voit bien la puissance
des missiles russes
qui ont frappé la tour
et les bâtiments autour.
Il faut savoir que
c'est toujours stratégique
d'essayer de couper
les moyens de communication
d'un pays qu'on est en train d'attaquer,
parce que ça permet
d'empêcher le gouvernement
de communiquer des informations
à la population
et ça peut aussi générer de la panique.
Là, en fait, il y avait
des civils dans cette voiture
au moment où le missile a explosé.
Finalement, la diffusion
de la télévision ukrainienne a pu reprendre
seulement quelques heures
après cette attaque.
Les bombardements et les combats
continuent de s'intensifier
un peu partout dans le pays
et sur les réseaux sociaux,
il y a des vidéos qui sont diffusées
qui montrent l'utilisation
d'armes de guerre interdites,
dans beaucoup de pays,
par les troupes russes,
comme ici à Tchernihiv,
avec des armes à sous-munitions.
Les forces russes
essaient d'encercler Kyiv.
Des combats, extrêmement violents,
ont lieu dans plusieurs villes
autour de la capitale,
notamment à Irpin,
qui est à seulement quelques kilomètres
au nord-ouest de Kyiv.
On est en train de partir vers Irpin.
Les troupes russes
se trouvent là-bas
et combattent l'armée ukrainienne
en ce moment.
Et on va essayer de se rapprocher, là-bas, pour filmer
les civils qui sont
en train d'essayer d'évacuer cette zone.
On est en train de rentrer
dans un no man's land
entre le dernier checkpoint militaire
de l'armée ukrainienne
et la ligne de front.
Tous les véhicules qu'on croise
sont des véhicules utilisés
pour évacuer la population d'Irpin.
Donc il y a des ambulances,
des véhicules privés, des bus,
et tout le monde essaie de sortir
la population civile
le plus rapidement possible
de cette zone.
On est vraiment tout proche
de la ligne de combat.
Ce que vous entendez là,
c'est des bombardements, des mortiers.
Vous pouvez voir que, même ici,
les combats ont été violents.
Il y a eu des bombardements,
je vais vous montrer.
24h plus tôt, l'armée russe a bombardé
extactement à cet endroit,
au moment même où des familles
étaient en train d'évacuer d'Irpin.
Ici, c'est vraiment un point de passage
pour la population qui veut s'enfuir
vers Kyiv.
Les autorités russes
le savent pertinemment,
même s'il y a des militaires ukrainiens
qui assurent le passage.
Donc, clairement,
ils visaient des civils,
ils voulaient faire des victimes civiles.
À cet endroit précis,
qui est le lieu de passage
des véhicules pour évacuer les gens,
les troupes russes
n'ont pas hésité à bombarder aussi.
Une fois évacués, les civils
arrivent au premier checkpoint de Kyiv,
où ils sont pris en charge
par les soldats de l'armée ukrainienne.
Au même moment, dans le sud de l'Ukraine,
Marioupol est devastée par les troupes russes.
Des quartiers entiers
ont été rayés de la carte.
L'hôpital de la ville
a été complètement détruit.
Les troupes russes sont désormais
à quelques kilomètres de Kyiv
et à l'intérieur de la ville, les Ukrainiens ont installé
des chekpoints un peu partout.
La capitale se prépare au pire.
Voilà ce qu'on a pu filmer à Kyiv,
côté ukrainien.
En réalité, c'est très difficile pour le moment
d'avoir des chiffres exacts
sur le nombre de victimes de cette guerre,
que ce soit côté ukrainien ou russe,
mais on sait déjà
qu'elle a fait des milliers de morts,
et selon l'ONU, environ 10 millions d'Ukrainiens
ont dû fuir leur foyer,
dont presque la moitié sont des enfants.